good morning John oh good for me maybe
not so much for you I've got a little
story to tell you so I put up a song
about protons and neutrons this
Wednesday and I went over pretty well
but I kept getting this comment over and
over again and I didn't know why I was
getting it people were all Oh Lord just
thank God it was not another Carl's jr.
and and I was like what the what I mean
know what Carl's jr. is because in
Florida where we grew up they were
called Hardee's though I still have not
even been to a Hardee's so I was
understandably very confused but then I
was rocking around the youtubes and I
saw that indeed there were a lot of
Carl's jr. ads up on the youtubes some
of them from my very favorite youtubers
the theme of the advertisement is how do
you eat your cows
jr. half pound lb for bellow mushroom
Black Angus $6 plus tax sandwich I came
a mover so I have decided the for John's
punishment since he didn't make a video
on Sunday he must eat a Carl's jr. I'll
be half pound $6 plus tax portobello
mushroom sandwich the way that only John
Green can know not blend Erised there's
a link to that video in the sidebar but
instead he must eat it in its
constituent parts that is correct and
you get to decide how he does it right
now at nerdfighters calm there are four
recipes that are nutritionally and
chemically extremely similar to a Carl's
jr. six outer plus tax Black Angus half
mushroom nothing about each of these
recipes contain 50 grams of protein 1000
milligrams of sodium 9 grams of sugar 47
grams of carbohydrates and 54 grams of
fat and you get to choose in what way
John eats those constituent parts so I
appreciate everybody going to
nerdfighters con right now and voting on
your favorite most punishing recipe John
I'll see you next week
I am looking forward to it
you